as ever these things are very charged in
the midst of a campaign
uh do you regret now putting out this
release
no we release our statistics at the same
time every year it's a mark of um those
uh who have needed support from food
banks over the last year our statistics
show the traffic through our food banks
the volume of people that needed support
and what it's shown on this occasion is
a 19 percent increase compared to last
year she didn't know that it wasn't
actually a million individuals that it
was some people coming twice well
whenever we release something you didn't
know that well whenever we release
ourselves you said a million people
which is not strictly accurate well
whenever we release our statistics we
always point out how that's calculated
and the fact that we're not measuring
unique clients we're measuring the
numbers of times somebody required three
days worth of food and over the last
year for the first time that has passed
a million which i think is deeply
concerning you know each one of these
people represents an individual that's
had to choose between paying a bill and
putting food on the table i mean it's
no one does the good work that the
trestle trust does no one doubts this is
a concerning issue but there is a
difference between half a million people
being dependent on
food banks and a million individuals
there's a proportion isn't there yes but
what we've been saying consistently
since 2004 we've been measuring our data
in exactly the same way and in the same
way that other organizations measure the
traffic through their services
accidentally
a million visits that wouldn't matter
what you said was a million people but
we've given three days worth of food to
a million people um over the last year
but some of them but actually they're
the same people
well so it's not a million people it's
half a million people we've given food
you've done it twice but it's half a
million anyway what do you make of this
statistical argument
well it's another reminder of some of
the difficulties we have as members of
the public in interpreting kind of
what's going on and we're seeing that in
the election campaign at the moment the
billions and trillions that are being um
offered to us and the public do
i mean the public almost
crying out for some for the official
statistics so they love statistics when
they come from the office of national
statistics when they come from
politicians they're less sure when they
come from something like the trustal
trust which is new i think this is a new
field that's one thing that you're
having to grapple with actually it's not
crime statistics or health statistics
that we're all used to food banks didn't
exist
four five six years ago as far as i'm
aware so i think this is an example
that's all actually coming to terms with
a new currency and that's the only
measurement in the uk
i mean
you may as i said be making perfectly
honest mistake but here's oxfam picking
it up
in response to figures from the trussell
trust out today which show the number of
food bank users in the uk has top 1
billion oxfam head of poverty said this
tessa jowl has retweeted that figure
rachel reeves has re
retweeted that figure so
it's understandable
that your research shows that people are
getting increasingly doubtful about
these statistics yes and i think the big
things i mean the classic thing is lies
down light and statistics isn't it and i
think what we what we find with the
public is they
we we can cope with some relatively
straightforward maths we can cope with
percentages but i think people start to
get a little bit concerned if they
haven't been pay attention to an issue
and then suddenly there's a big argument
about this currency and i guess that's
what we're seeing today the arguments
about the currency and it's taken away
perhaps from the broader issue at large
what about the arguments that are being
made
in the political arguments about food
banks some people are saying well now
job centers direct people to food banks
so of course you get more visitors and
citizen advice bureau do that as well
and they're also saying that there's a
general awareness of food banks so maybe
people in need but
more food banks being set up so more
people are going to go to them a bit
like you build more roads and you get
more cars well over the last few years
we've seen an obvious growth in a number
of food banks as responding to the need
in their community but we've seen a
disproportionate growth in the volume of
clients who are referred to us everybody
we help in a food bank has been referred
by a care professional organization
locally that sees people every day in
crisis a sure start worker said to me on
monday that you know people don't turn
up to them asking for a food parcel they
have to spot the signs that somebody
hasn't been eating in order to refer
them to the food bank for some
short-term assistance so we are
confident that those people who come to
the food bank are in a genuine need and
what we're saying is we've seen a
significant increase in that need over
the past few years
what what does the public think when you
survey them on things like uh equality
and poverty in society do they think
that it's on the increase it's
poverty itself tends not to register
very very highly i think what we are
finding i perhaps think some of the
points that you were just raising is
people are you know are increasingly you
know the whole theory we're seeing in
terms of the election at the moment is
the the the economy is on the mend um
but the public haven't really seen it
yet and that's one of the problems for
example the conservatives are seeing at
the moment uh and so i guess we're
finding we're not so much funny that
poverty is is rising up the agenda so
it's top top top but it's certainly a
bit more than it was previously and
things like housing also coming to the
fall as well but you were at sos murray
now you you're an annual event where you
look at people's delusions if you like
you know what are some of the examples i
mean immigration is one of them
yes exactly i mean i think the public
the public at the moment think we think
that 24 percent of the of the country at
large are immigrants it's 13
we think something like 15 of our
teenage girls are getting pregnant uh
it's about three percent so in terms of
where the starting point is if you like
in terms of what's happening in the
country at the moment we do have a
tendency to exaggerate we in the media
possibly a little bit to blame for that
well who can possibly comment what do
you think does the media get this wrong
well it's really hard there's always a
story behind statistics and there is a
story behind the trustless statistics
the same as every other statistic and
you know it's really hard uh there are
uh you know lots of rhetoric but when
you see i mean you've been quite clear
what you were saying in your report but
when you see headlines saying a million
people does does that worry you do you
think i wish they hadn't done that which
they'd put in a small print well we we
still um i still hold that you know we
gave a food to a million people last
year for the first time the referrals to
our feedbacks past a million and that's
concerning so i think those headlines
with a single child saying i fed 365
children last year isn't it it's a bit
like the nhs saying that they had a
million visits to their to their
hospitals um we don't say that those
visits were all different people they
could have been the same person with
multiple injuries all right thank you
both very much indeed for talking about
this